oh oh wow we're live already
i upd streamlabs updated just before
uh we set up the stream here and i guess
maybe that update oh my god we're live
yeah maybe that update means that they
have really uh you guys know what
detected
their link up it's maybe it's been a few
weeks since we've done live streams
and we choose the times to do live
streams usually when majority of our
viewers
according to our youtube analytics are
not watching youtube
yes we should be live streaming from
eight a.m to noon
analytics said you should be yeah
anywhere from 8 a.m to noon is when they
said the live stream
i was like yeah ain't gonna happen
youtube live streams is what we do i
guess that's
that must be pandemic life because under
normal circumstances i was like does
nobody
like i know some people who watch us are
are youths but does no one have a job
uh thank you guys so much for being here
it's been a while since dinner live
stream how's everyone's week going so
far how's everyone's weekend going
say hi in the chat alicia disney logan
tm darth yoda dom forest i see bradley b
judy bradley i heard about the adoption
congratulations hey jenna welcome to the
chat
oh snap adapt sorry let me move this to
where you can read it still
will i tweak a couple john is just
fixing some things so we could have a
smooth additional things here
thank you pitbull that's really sweet of
you dragon animations
digging the hair y'all i know it's it's
it's winter time i mean
where's his loot crate daredevil beanie
dude that's what i do
it's a classic like if you ever get an
action figure made out of you that'll be
one of the interchangeable
beanies that you're you know that's very
true action figure we'll get to where
are we set up yet
we're we gotta do we gotta go live we're
pretty damn live right now
we're pretty damn live i'm not gonna lie
and then i was doing some math too and i
was like oh yeah we do get way more
viewers when we've done live streams
early on in the day
or early afternoon yeah
but that's something i love about i love
about um
doing this time because it just seems
like such a much more intimate stream
yeah it's the and it's the last thing of
the week and yeah it's like it's
saturday evening
it's it's sort of like a club of some
kind yeah because we meet up between 9
to 11 every morning so we could easily
live stream in the morning if we wanted
to yeah but there's just something about
this where it's just
oh it feels like more of a fun capper to
end the week sarah campbell
sarah delores sandoval
hello who are you guys we're greg and
john
and uh yeah the real three jacks
oh what's up uh shouts out to pop
culture podcast over there i actually i
talked to spencer uh last night so go
uh listen to that if you care to listen
to me converse with spencer for two
hours not gonna happen
it's okay not for me don't worry about
it all right but uh i'm glad you're
finally anyone who's
not you yeah i know it was a lot of fun
r.i.p una sanus yes goodbye to them
they're a great channel i saw the very
end of unasanas last night
oh good for you man and uh it is the end
yes there's a cat in here which me the
cat would did not want to leave
and then because i closed the door the
cat now wants to get the hell out of
here yeah that's the way this cat
operates
he's making adorable muffins in my scarf
right now though so i think he's
hi aisha hi sophie all right mikey
welcome
alrighty so the today's stream is gonna
be tell us the best and worst movie
taglines this just sounds like a really
fun one to do um there's so many and i'm
surprised we haven't done this topic
before
because there are some that are just
absolutely terrible
and there are some that are just so damn
great
yes um and we got a whole list of them
yeah
so hey don forest welcome but uh i don't
know let's i see some people
someone's already contributed to our
super chat really appreciate that don't
worry we'll cover super chats and we'll
cover the ones in the stream labs thank
you guys who want to contribute to that
means a lot
but let's go into it all right here's
one that i got
uh that i really love because i've seen
this one
on the worst tagline list
many times and i'm here today to argue
that this is one of the best
taglines in movie history and i know
it's one you love and i don't even think
you've seen the movie
but i know it's one yellow yeah okay um
but i love this one
and let me know what you guys think of
this one
crank high voltage he was dead
he got better yeah i think that is one
of the best absolutely taglines
and anytime i see a worse tagline list
for some reason
that movie is on there is it cheesy
yes but does it encapsulate crank
does it does it tell you like yeah that
that works
for this kind of movie and only this
kind of movie because he he in the in
the end of crank one he falls off a
plane
smashes his whole body on a concrete
he's dead and then it's like what's the
best way to explain this to audiences
who were like i thought he died he was
dead
like yeah that works for crank for a
crank it works exactly so
that one is a great one i don't give a
[ __ ] what people say no
that's a great tagline everyone says
it's one of the worst
that is no i think that's one that that
deserves
to end up on both every worst tagline
and every best tagline list because
it's truly both like it is it's silly
and and
silly but also it's yeah the perfect
tagline
for what i understand about that movie
so johnny what's yours what's one you
got
this one uh is i think from one of the
uh
like one of the more obscure posters are
a couple taglines for this movie but uh
one of the taglines for the thing
was uh man is the warmest place to hide
which
is just like a nice creepy sort of
uh indicative of the movie but in an
abstract kind of way thing
yeah and uh yeah that was one that
always uh stuck with me
uh also there's a it's it's it was long
term i always remember parts of it but
trick-or-treats was a
poison drowning claw or knife so many
ways to take a life
was it was jaws the revenge the one that
coined
this time it's personal was that the one
that started it
this time it's personal i think that's
at least
i i i feel like it might have happened
beforehand by happenstance but i feel
like that's the one that
solidified its meme status yeah
uh i think the best i honestly think the
best movie tagline is alien
i mean do you know what you got you know
right after if you search your brain
hard enough you'll know it
in space no one can hear you scream
that is a brilliant tagline because that
yeah that encapsulates the tone of the
world yeah
that's such a brilliant tag line and i
think that's the job of a tagline it's
just
i i've been using this phrase an awful
lot lately sell the sizzle not the steak
yeah and i feel like that is the perfect
sizzle
for uh for a tagline like that but i've
seen some great ones in here we gotta
read something in the chat and we'll get
to the super chats i promise thank you
everyone's contributing there
mikey mcmahon saying uh great things
come in bears
yogi bear see i hate those kind
where they're just so lazy the late
the laziest one one of the laziest ones
i've ever seen is one i've committed to
memory since i saw the poster
many many many many years ago for a film
you guys might not even know
i think david goyer did this oh goody
it's called
the unborn and the tagline is it
wants to be born and i think the word
now is there somewhere on the text yeah
the poster i think it's it wants to be
born now i'm like what
that is the laziest tagline ever
the unborn the tagline is it wants to be
born now
and like that's what the yogi bear one
makes me think of great things come in
bears it's it
works but in a way that completely
there's an old like
the improv uh comedy sports troupe used
to have a growner foul for
jokes like that that i'm like it works
as a joke
oh but oh just face palm yes you know
but there are some taglines like that
too that literally are just like we're
just gonna explain the movie
but then there's tag lines like um
what's funny what's fascinating about
star wars specifically is
it's its original tagline is i think i
don't know if the word it's a long time
or it's just a long time i'm pretty sure
it's a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away
that and i think a lot of people fill in
the blank wouldn't real
i i don't know if that i don't think
someone for all them obviously but it's
a long time ago in a galaxy far far away
it's not only the movie's tagline it's
it's also the start to all the star wars
movies
you know i think that is brilliant and
i think that's like i think spider-man
won
no no i thought it was with great power
comes great responsibility but i don't
think that's the actual tagline of the
movie
but anyway uh yes sarah campbell's
listed one just now that i love
that's another one i love ghost ship
it's called sea
evil s-e-a-c
evil that was brilliant oh goodness like
titans will clash of titans tied into a
classic
oh like
that's oh good you mean the thing the
title's promising me is probably likely
to happen
if avengers infinity war was
the war is forever [ __ ] like that the
avengers joined the war
yeah okay so dumb how about this how
about this because i feel like this one
teeters but i love it uh sleepy hollows
is
heads will roll that's brilliant which i
think is fun
but in the right kind of way where it's
not too funny you know
uh let's see here i saw mimi m put up uh
on
air and unaware of the truman show
that's a pretty good one
all right we got some super chats i know
we've been here for a little bit
but i want to read off one more um of
course put on a hat put it on a happy
face joker of course
uh let's see here the man of your dreams
is back for nightmare on elm street too
that is a wonderful tackling i did not
know that was attacked
the man of your dreams is brilliant
a quiz show shouts out to bernie
alvarado for just referencing that movie
ever
50 million people watch but no one saw a
thing that's good
truman show no quiz show i wish uh ray
finds and various other you know it's a
it's a like a period drama but it's a a
really good movie
was what a day i mean a hallway
conversation you might come in here a
little bit late but we
that is the first one we kicked it off
with um all right let's see what's in
store
let's let's get to some super chats
junkies can you get us going because
we only got like a few super chats but i
want to make sure we honor them yeah
getting super big time live die repeat
live
it was interesting because that that was
one of the rare i think that's the only
case
i've heard of with taglines where that
should have been
the the title of the movie for a lot of
people but honest and i'm kind of in the
uh
odd camp there because i'm one of the
few people who actually thinks edge of
tomorrow is a really smart title i think
a lot of people
like that title when i'm part of the
game that's like no i actually really
like that title i think it works
for sure and live die repeats a decent
i mean live die repeat is not really
listen
sounds cool it sounds cool but it just
sounds like a typical timeline
yeah yeah yeah time loop movie yeah it's
so blunt
it's so blind you can see you could put
that on happy death day or groundhog day
or uh palm springs you could just put
live die repeat there
it's almost right yeah so i think
there's something
kind of weak sauce about it yet people
are like that should have been the title
of the movie
i think on some versions of the home
video they did switch it
yeah there's some yeah like circumstance
like that the tooth hurts the tooth
fairy brilliant some people hate that
one i think that's a smart ass one also
tooth fairy you can't handle the tooth
a lot of truth jokes uh let's see here
bernie alvarado
bernie thank you so much for
contributing to the super chat my buddy
clever tagline in my opinion back to the
future he was never in time for his
classes
he wasn't in time for his dinner then
one day he wasn't in his time at all
hey that's a cute one
i feel like that that is the setup of
the movie exactly yeah that's a
lot that's a tagline and a log line i
feel like the way you get away with
doing that is yeah when you pose it as
either like a
a rhyme or like the setup to a tail or
something where yeah you're trying to
get
people like filling in the blank of that
like yeah that that's really crisp but i
i'm
i feel like we don't get as many of
those i feel like tag lines at the
moment are
more geared towards like you know
succinctness
yeah i think the taglines have to
capistly plot and tone the most
yeah and i think that one while a little
long for back to the future i think it
overall encapsulates it pretty well hell
yeah hell yeah bernie alvarado
sarah campbell alrighty sarah campbell i
haven't been in the last couple streams
missed you boys missed you too sarah
thank you so much for being here
um one of my favorites is halloween h2o
this summer terror won't be taking
a vacation uh favorites as in one of
your favorite bad ones or favorites as
in one of your favorite good ones
because is that a guilty pleasure that's
honestly a pretty bad tackle
i can see it's guilty pleasure value
because it it doesn't work in so many i
mean like
tara won't be taking a vacation for
summer vacation all right fine like it's
a it's a goofy enough joke but also like
does that movie take place in the
summertime i feel like all the halloween
movies take place
halloween halloween is not in the summer
so
like it does it geographically and time
makes sense to that's
true that's true uh but hey man i mean
to each their own you know the
difference i go to bat for crank too and
that's always on the worst of lists
thank you sarah and i like halloween h2o
okay it's i think one of the better
sequels
joe swallows i hope you don't get made
fun of too much for that last name
where's sck where's that from sck
oh oh goodness um i don't know
at all we're not looking it up we're not
looking we're not looking we're not
wasting any more goddamn time we're not
i love your work guys keep up the good
work
thank you joe swallows do you get made
fun of is that a real last name
that i could see that being a very
unfortunate last name
or a very fortunate last name if you use
it to your advantage you know if you
become like
a competitive actually swallow yeah or
uh
or that sperm swallower yeah dude if
you're just out there giving the
fellatio
that one works too it both works do him
both
if that is his maybe he's maybe he's
marketing himself with joe swallows
right now yeah
i'm single and ready to mingle and i'm
joe swallows
you still love our swallows i'm sorry
i'll thank you movie tag lines joe
swallows
this summer ain't nothing
joe from swallows not taking a vacation
adam uh eric horseman swallows damn
straight he does
um i bet adam adam lorem
yes adam lonza adam
earlier i mean a lot of times these
great taglines do come in the form of
just rhyming it
yeah you know yeah and i mean it's
that's the the tricky tight wire
the act that you can walk is like that's
a cute play on a well-known phrase
and and it works i think yeah as it
pertains to the chickens
i feel like sometimes attempts to do
this kind of thing uh
turn out pretty pretty uh cringe but
that's why the tooth
that the you can't handle the tooth for
the tooth fairy a movie i've never seen
perfect
i think that's a great tag line yeah
that's a wonderful tagline
but yeah also the thing is you got to
think too in terms of because taglines
are all about marketing
that it really is so i'm wondering if
you if you're driving
and you haven't heard of the tooth fairy
and then you just see that poster
of dwayne johnson with tooth fairy wings
and then
he says you can't handle the tooth are
you just going to roll your eyes at that
or are you going to be like
we should take the family you know jack
nicholson
dwayne johnson that's where my mic is
i like when they market kids movies with
taglines that are obviously playing on
very adult
movie questions you wouldn't have seen
oh
let's refresh this really quick oh my
god sorry let's see oh you're good
you're
good baby you're a little bit delayed
here that's my least favorite
trend you know if we ever you know fine
art is what if we ever need to
catch a break here on the stream all we
have to do is like pretend to freeze
frame
and then just like okay just take a
little bit of a breather we're good
okay i mean i'm talking too much wait
wait
before we pull up the the ones on the
street labs i want to read the norbit
ones
the film that made eddie murphy lose an
oscar and dream girls oh no wait is that
a real tagline i could see that be a
real tackling
is that is somebody verify this for us
wait is predator too real um
yes i think it is he's in town with a
few days
to kill is that real rosie that's
hilarious i feel like that's
if that's not actually predator 2 i
think it's a real tagline but i don't
know why rosie would lie to us about
that
um john name a movie let's come up with
a tag line really fast before we move on
let's just invent a tagline i don't know
most taglines okay
okay clock stoppers clock stoppers
frozen in time hey that works i mean
it's not
is that the real one because i could see
it being there not i mean
if you want to look it up you can it's
not i think
uh like it's not i don't know it is a
quick one
well there's a plot of it clock stoppers
is like i don't know they get a time
machine wrist watch thing and they gotta
go do some kind of uh
mission that involved i think they
freeze time the only way to
save time is to freeze time
see i like yeah that's a good like bad
tack like because that's like
because it's just a statement see our
ball of the undefeated said whoever wins
we lose i know that one a vp that's a
great call
i think that's a wonderful one yeah yeah
i think it's
appropriately funny but also you could
say that for any
horror movie clash up yeah freddy vs
jason whoever wins we lose
who's gonna kill more teens i don't know
love is in the hair whoever wins disney
never loses
whoever wins disney i mean they'll make
it back
on something um would the passion of the
christ have a tagline
i almost said crucify this but that's
just because of that
family guy that yeah that's not he was
dead
he got better get clean he was dead he
got better
that should be the tagline for the
follow-up to passion of the christ
that's right
the resurrection of the christ he was
dead he got better
three days later that'd be hysterical oh
my god jason statham can finally play
jesus
we got someone's here in uh streamlabs
johnny can you can you se is this it is
that that guy for the title get the
title out of here i got it
john is that it can you adjust this
punch it in some most people watch on
their phones
okay i think i think we can punch in one
more gotta keep it over that's not what
it is that's too close
john all right that's this this is the
punch this is what we got
sl7 superman you believe a man can fly
is
a an amazing tagline because that does
capture the wonder and the spirit of
superman absolutely and it's a moment in
time and it and i feel like that's what
it
i mean that is that was the tagline too
i think is that from the comics you'll
believe a man could fly
i know they used it for the george
reeves tv show
but it did do that it did and at the
time it made it
the capture was an awe-inspiring it's
it's a connection that's a great one to
connect to the audience
with yeah of like an emotional
experience you're gonna have
super superman you'll believe a man can
fly like there is such a joy and beauty
to it
whoever came up with that [ __ ]
deserves a million dollars
they're amazing dude oh mimi's got the
clock stuff
freeze the future what if you had the
power to stop time
and the adventure of a lifetime in a few
mere seconds
can somebody in the chat find me the
limitless one
i remember liking that one yeah i don't
remember it
um but can someone find me the limitless
one all right what did phleb say flap
how you doing
left d two great tag lines that greg
will definitely recognize fear can hold
you prisoner
hope can set you free craig is failing
to recognize
what else that one is that shawshank
redemption
is that i think it you'll know by the is
one his life is like a box of chocolates
you never know what you're gonna
get and i haven't seen both of those
movies and i don't recognize the first
one
so that's probably shawshank redemption
that's a great game you set up there
i really appreciate that buddy it's good
um
[Laughter]
goody actually i really that that
tagline does make me wanna
put on shawshank redemption but i gotta
beat somebody right man miles morales
watch live stream live reaction to
shawshank redemption
thank you flem eric horseman eric horst
means
this is why we cannot say the [ __ ]
our own contributions on the themes
first
you know why because we end up getting
to the super chats eventually
spoiling it for everybody people i've
i've heard people say we take too long
to start with the super chats
and then we and then i'm like ah [ __ ]
someone already said it and you gave me
such a big one too
thank you everybody for the contribution
dude we'll cut it out of much of a later
video
my favorite movie of all time best that
is that's your favorite movie of all
time
in space no one could hear you scream
alien
eric horseman we're going to visit you
in georgia one day
now's the time to go to george time to
go to georgia
while everything's calm what is the
aliens one
uh has anyone found the possibility has
anyone found
the limitless one a niece is drunk hell
yeah
in space no one can hear you [ __ ]
aliens
oh yeah i by the end of this live stream
i want to develop an ability to become
like a freestyler but for movie tag
lines oh my god guys this is a
terrible tagline look at this this
okay so let's keep in mind all right the
alien tagline
is my best is uh in space no one can
hear you scream
here's aliens
this time there's more this time it's
war
there are some places in the universe
you don't want to go alone i didn't even
know that was the tagline until five
seconds ago
that is terrible that's just somebody
hyping the movie up for you oh no that
is a that's a horrible one i don't think
any of the
this time there's more is also a
terrible this time
the best of them but but yeah hi mike
lynch thanks for being here
what's weird is it but i way prefer the
aliens i actually prefer aliens over
aliens so
yeah well you know you can't win that's
why it's not perfect because it doesn't
have the tagline advantage and if anyone
in this chat
come pitches the tag comes up with a
tagline
randomly rewrites one or submits a great
one
just highlight them in the comments and
show them some love you know
people take time to type [ __ ] aisha
kenya
the total recall they stole his mind now
he wants it back
not bad did anyone find the limitless
one i feel like robocop has a good
tagline
i did i wrote robocop down somewhere a
part man
part machine oh cop
a good one that's a solid one the longer
you wait the harder it gets the 40 year
old virgin
uh oh yeah tina's hot
is it tina shot dog or tina's hot dog
it's tin a shot dog
much peanut john you made the joke
working tina's hot dog
so john can you read off her her stream
lap here please
it's funny and annoying how in german
they keep
the english title and then the tagline
is the literal translation
wait a minute wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait what does that mean so it is
an interesting thing right so are you
saying that they keep the english
word as the title of the movie and then
the tagline just becomes
whatever that word directly translates
to in german no matter how
clunky that is like the thing is i i
love
and you can go down rabbit holes on the
internet of movie
posters and stuff from like overseas
from various places
and like the way things get retitled and
also re-taglined
uh is fascinating and very uh amusing
oh i think a army of darkness is called
captain supermarket or something
in japan oh this john you digested that
fact way better than i did but
mimi m has found the limitless tagline
yes so i gotta read it out i gotta read
it out loud
time it's uh limitless is it can solve
any problem it can unlock your potential
but once the world is yours
everybody wants a piece i don't remember
loving it
i thought it was a lot better in workers
before
i feel like maybe the trailer has a line
that probably feels like a good tackle
there's there's oh there's more
uh what if a pill could make you rich
and powerful miranda's coming
doing this one uh what if a pill could
make you rich and powerful it can solve
any problem it can unlock your potential
i mean that's a nice excellent some
excellence in the chat what's up buddy
excellent excellent excellent
uh and then you know supply a more
uh you know mexican instrumental
for the air guitars i wish you could
swear in taglines because carter lovejoy
said a good day to die hard just [ __ ]
die already like that dude i wish you
could really swear in potentials i mean
the club one of the closest ones they
got to is
kind of just an implication was 40 year
old virgin
it's not a swear word but the longer you
wait the harder it gets is a really
clever one and double automatically
talking about a man's erection so
anyhow let's go back to uh the stream
labs you guys keep submitting great ones
there's an infinite amount of movies to
submit yeah on this one seriously it's
just
around there's so many great ones like
this is the you could do this topic
every month forever i'm gonna let the
cat copper copper's gonna go outside and
i'm gonna read
what tongue punch fart box has to say
deontay debya it's good to hear from you
my friendo taglines from some of my
favorite movies
bonus points if you can guess the movie
all right i'll reveal the answers later
one suit up
is that men in black yeah i think it's
been in black yeah
two you don't get to 500 friends without
making the social [ __ ] network
[ __ ]
you know what we should do for the next
thank you evan bradley i just started
commenting
we should do for the next the next one
okay
um the next live stream since we're
getting all this homework
yes we should do um and it doesn't have
to be the ones because we're obviously
missing some because we can't keep up
with every cost
we should do guess this and tagline
guess this is a
game okay like we should make it a game
or if we want to turn it into a game now
we can
yeah yeah but if we did against this
tagline that would be a really fun one
uh tongue punch fart box you've just
heard that uh an epic of epic epicness
i'm assuming this one is
hilgren that's scott pilgrim i think so
oh it's not epic movie
no no i i think epic movie probably was
stupider than this
an epic of epic epicness i i think it's
scott
scott pilgrim oh yeah someone said that
earlier [ __ ] pilgrim
um and then he said oh he gave answers
here
up oh it's the incredibles suit
up down what was the minute black people
men in black and space the wicked are
you screaming
in space no one can hear you
uh you know tell someone to freeze
because you're with the others
i feel like i should know that yeah i
feel like men in black has
a distinctive one i mean taglines suck
they need to come up with them oh yeah
but when you get a good one i imagine
like
i i want to know if there are people who
just specifically do that or if it's
just like i don't know
marketing firms blah blah thank you
tongue punch fartbox i appreciate that
and hugh in the chat i see you're
quoting
um uh what's her name switch from the
matrix
bradley blitz so hey bradley i from uh
eric
told me that you're you uh i don't know
how much you want me to reveal here
told me you're adopted so
congratulations
hey that seriously memory serving me
correctly congratulations
pepe friend how are you doing thanks for
being here uh bradley is saying uh the
tagline for bill and tetz john
john listen up listen up okay we gotta
learn to listen to each other during
these streams
all right we have a habit of when i'm
talking you're reading the chat and when
you're talking i'm reading the chat and
then we're not
we're both gonna be reading bradley's on
this stream
all right the tagline for
bill and ted excellent venture
summarizes the characters and
perfect and plot perfectly history is
about to be rewritten
by two guys who can't spell oh
that's oh what a good one that's a
delight that's a wonderful
one yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
who comes up with tagline i know i know
like did somebody involve like it makes
you think like does the writer ever get
to do that it seems like something that
would probably just go to like a random
poster designer or something but
like because i mean i've been writing a
lot this year but for everything i
write i'm asked to come up with a log
line for it and that's not the same as a
tagline obviously
but man if you could come up with a
tagline that also is sort of like a log
line because i hate coming up with long
lines i think long lines are the most
annoying thing in the world to write
how to like pitch the plot of this in
two sentences i'm like oh
man and do it in a way that's everything
it's fun but it tells you exactly what
it is but it has the themes but it's fun
can i just hire someone to do this yeah
can i get like an algorithm to turn one
out
ryan johnson is in the chat saying how
you both doing we're doing good thank
you buddy
flev doran back at it again uh the
godfather three all the powers on earth
can't change destiny what is that
real power on earth can't change destiny
that seems like a real hold on i'm gonna
look this
up oh up you broke the barrier of
research
when the [ __ ] is godfather aliens all
the power on earth
what is godfather all about
i mean i guess there's an argument to be
made for destiny
all right oh he's right all the powers
on earth can't change destiny real power
can't be given
it must be taken all right but a
director's cut might
i just don't really think of you know
there's an unfortunate
inheritance and legacy within the
corleone family but
i don't think it's about destiny but i
guess it's about destiny
whatever hi jacob what's up baltimore
maybe that's part of the argument is is
it
is it destiny or is it just you know the
the machinations of one man
within a family empire thank you uh
joseph carter solis and then let's show
and then we also have
so bizarre adventure okay let's put this
away for a second let's check in on this
on the chat and the streams
on the streams ones and so somebody uh
pointed out rush hour i think it's rush
hour two
is was like the fastest i feel like one
of the rush hour ones was like the
fastest hands in the east meets the
biggest mouth in the west that's a great
one yeah
gamer movie dude who are you going to
call ghostbusters it's it's cool when
the tagline
also becomes the quote like star wars
like
answer the call answer the call
ghostbusters answer the call as the
official title of that movie now
is it really yeah it was the tagline and
now it is the title
of ghostbus they changed the title why
of the to differentiate it from
not being a direct remake of
ghostbusters because that's why why
don't they give it to the remake
no no it is the remake that's what i'm
saying oh i think it's gonna be original
no
god no no no no no no no it's not called
who you're gonna call ghostbusters it's
it's
the remake is called ghostbusters answer
the call now
carter lovejoy in the chat is saying if
2020 was a movie the tagline would be
it went from good to bad to ugly to
worst to hell to hope to victory
victory depending on who you're talking
to carter yeah woo
if you're talking about the majority
oh golly what is victory in 20 20 20.
[Music]
insane yeah i already said spoke up
man there's victory going around i get
the emails
uh from all over the place and there's a
lot of victory going around we're so
tired of winning
is liar liar is that toy in the chat is
saying
liar liar it's trust me yeah is that
true oh what a good one that's a perfect
one
yeah that's and it's like yeah because
it's perfectly in character it's
perfectly like his little liar would say
yo
jared jared never returned the chassis
and size doesn't matter godzilla 98.
that is i think that's a really good one
for a terrible movie i'm with it like
great tagline
terrible movie there's there's a lot of
categories you can come up with this
tagline
yeah you do like great movie terror uh
great uh
or a great movie terrible tag lines or a
terrible tagline screen you can flip it
and then for the bonus point would that
tagline still work had that godzilla
been an actually good
godzilla movie oh [ __ ] is that adam
adams said
um in the chat zoolander three percent
body fat one percent brain activity i
think i have seen that
poster yes clever as [ __ ] or else i'm
mandela ing myself but yeah i like that
one
hi brendan v hello brendan v
um okay we we're behind on some super
chats here
let's bring it back up yo you guys
die heart die hard 2 die harder is
uh that's i thought that was the actual
title
die hard 2 die harder i thought for the
longest time it was the actual title
oh wow it is really stupid
what's weird it's i think it's a
stupid-ass tagline
but a great title
because it just evolves i think that's
when it dips more into cheese territory
yeah
i think i think die hard too die hard is
actually a weirdly good title but for
some reason not a good tagline
it would the separation takes some of
the oomph out of it yeah
if it's just like a one-two punch of
title and escalation it's like yeah
let's
do this because i think naked bill
sadler i thought it was
um uh like that's why i i would i want
that for all movies that are just like
like a quiet place too quiet harder oh
be a great one you know
is it not the title too quiet basically
john type in
can you type in die hard 2 for me then
we'll pull up the super chips
it's just called die hard 2.
yeah it's yeah it's only called die hard
too yeah
i thought it was diehard i thought it
was the title die hard too
i thought die hard die hard boogaloo wow
that's surprising i see bradley in the
chats also confused
i saw a great the only thing more
terrifying than the last 12 minutes of
this film or the final 92
for suspiria that's fun let's try to
avoid some certain conversations in the
chat if we can
it's it's not about happens it happens
we can't prevent it yeah dude
let's see here well it's not the time
but it's not the best let's see what
happens
uh what's going on here our window is
wide open for the first time ever doing
a live stream so if we're like swearing
and all this stuff
it's nice let's go let's go into here
all right
johnny yes siree bob arena oh damn we
got quite a bit that we're behind on
okay frying was the last one
dolan duck
life is for living see i can't speak on
that because i haven't seen charlie
saying cloud or even is that
this is zac efron movie isn't it yeah
yeah i don't
know what it's about but uh that sounds
lazy i
i can guess what the tone is and yeah
it seems like a tagline that probably
fits its movie but that probably is not
particularly back up the vibe i get
where's
sck what's that currency showdown
entertainment currency
network with a k yeah what is that
what is that silent network
swedish so is swedish
[Music]
i'm not doing a swedish accent i was
just going high-pitched voices just
octaves this is my swedish impression i
don't actually know what swedish people
sound like
dangerously close to becoming an adam
sandler character adam sandler and
mickey mouse had a baby is what i just
did
i'm adam sander and mickey mouse's child
ooh on the air unaware that's a good all
right so what do we got here
all right so many who that is who that
is that's f h
for firehouse hey firehouse big
fan from london uk keep up the great
vids well thank you thank you
we got some eastern people you're you're
people here relatively
eastward of us yeah european people
watching
europe the uk and and also europe
because now there's
there's not yet well we are at a point
which
i'm under the belief will never ever get
to we're at a point where we never have
to edit
just let other people do it um or will
we just livestream all reactions
yeah yeah we should just we'll get to a
point where we're just
every every day we'll do a different
live stream at a different time
just to talk to this part of the world
yeah yeah who's whose noon is this
let's find out oh gosh i like it
i want to do it the mission is a man
saving private ryan
could also be a romantic movie
i need to find a date for the wedding
and then the tagline is the mission is
man it would be fun to take taglines
just like how we talked about them doing
uh the crank
tag line for just for the christ yeah
for a passion of the christ follow-up
he's dead but got better
you could do that it would be fun to
like switch some around because you
could do that would
save your private ryan's a great one
yeah the mission is a man
or you could swap it with the martian
bring him home
you remember all those poses matt
damon's face that's what it is it just
says
bring him home what a stupid test it was
not a
was just matt damon's face with giant
block text
bring him home he's like you could have
you you could come by going up get
i have to engage with to like help you
get him home in the movie steven herbert
stefan oh dude you didn't say anything i
appreciate the super chat but he didn't
say anything say something hey there
no this is this is uh uh for all those
movie posters that don't have a tagline
and and that's a bad tagline is not to
any tagline at all
or the best tagline if you have a
particularly good title
oh mk songbird just said one in the chat
said austin powers the spy who shagged
me
is you i'm coming again baby is that
real
that's brilliant yeah baby oh
dude i love when you could get away with
an edgy tagline yeah just because of
technicality
that and 40 year old virgin those are so
clever yes
oh that is so clever are you swapping
who are you going to call it
godzilla oh nowadays nowadays yeah
uh let's see here uh what do we got uh i
could see it carter lovejoy again any of
those sappy inspire thank you carter
any of those sappy inspirational type
family dramas and it's something like
this christmas bee be inspired and
uplifted it's always the worst
oh okay i i i i wrote one down
where is it let me just find it uh john
okay four christmases since they're
talking about crappy christmas ones
four christmases is a shitty ass tagline
father her mother his mother and her
father
all in one day it's like could you not
be any lazier with coming up with the
tagline
that's all that yeah i i it wants to be
cute but then it's just a
jumble of pronouns pronouns and titles
and pronouns and titles
it's like avengers end game snapped away
build a new gauntlet snap them back
snapped away
snaps back snapping back into action if
if avengers end game was a cheesy ass
one
back in snap snap in black
if if if avengers game was a cheesy ass
one i would have liked
like snapping back into action yeah snap
back attack
snap back to gravity oh there goes
rabbit he choked
what's the eight mile tag line eight
mile tag line yeah
he was dead between got better between
seven and nine
seven nine there's eight
seven eight nine oh buddy
all right so uh who's this michael swift
hey michael swift do you get a lot of
hey you must be related to taylor huh
don't worry i'm not making fun of you
i've been getting that my whole life
with jessica alba fortunately
she's nowhere near as famous as she once
was so i get that question
way less are you agile michael swift
return of the living
dead uh here's the tagline they're back
from the grave
and ready to party oh snap i'm down
with that return of the living dead is
the the one that i constantly think is a
part of the romero franchise
yeah it's the 80s one with the weird
like toxin spill
and there's the tar man zombie and the
graveyard and the nudity and
yeah oh that's a good one yeah that's a
fun movie
and then we got stephen herbert again
ooh he actually has text this time
thank you steven with great power comes
great responsibility
perf i don't know about that i mean
about it no i mean i was thinking about
the future ones i want to know what the
other spider-man ones were
here john take over he was a boy he got
spider
the amazing spider-man yes
saving the world takes a little hard and
a big johnson yeah i like that i
like that one is a little bit of an eye
roll but but i i'll take it for the uh
silly untold story begins
oh no not that
oh is that what it was not the secret
subway train i
altered your blood when you were born
because you're the chosen one peter
story
no that is terrible april o'neil these
turtles belong to you all
oh hey everyone in the chat people the
chat already way ahead of me here
let's see here um no i mean with great
power comes great responsibility that's
you know that is actually perfect if you
can take
the a quote from the movie and just make
it the tagline
but not fail at it like like how the
matrix revolutions did
oh god what was that everything that has
a beginning has an
end and i believe oracle is the one who
says it in that movie
which is just an awful tagline yeah
choose something you might as well have
just gone with get revolutionized
it's part three guys and long running
franchises are mostly for horror and
schlock so i guess it's the last
let's see here uh oh who's this your
piranha pastor
wow [ __ ] crazy ass name
angels are coming angels are coming
ancient africa africa africa
the first casualty of war i'm quoting
and you could take that as a good thing
or a bad thing yeah
always i'm totally neutral oh god the
first casualty of war
is innocence platoon um oh wow
oliver i could see oliver stone coming
up with that one the first casualty of
wars that's
innocence that's a heavy what makes you
think that's a heavy well you are a
piranha pastor way to preach
man holy [ __ ] that's a good one i like
it that's the thoughtful one
and and akin to the movie chelsea brown
really quick uh a tagline
it's those little phrases you see on a
movie poster it's usually some witty
line that is trying to you know make the
movie appeal just a little bit more to
you
you know it's like uh crank two he was
dead
he got better great too it's the most
quoted tagline of this whole stream
um ghostbusters who you gonna call
that's a tagline i haven't seen denise's
name that much here in the chat and it's
kind of bothering him she's drunk
she went home that's a tagline
she was drunk she got better uh
amarillo66 thank you buddy they think uh
they think innocent think helpless think
again
baby geniuses oh clever i don't even
know what the poster looks like but i
can just
imagine that yes you're driving down the
road
think innocent think helpless think
again oh perfect
perfect style this movie is gonna be a
box office sensation
and they've made more than one of those
movies
so it must have worked it must have
appealed to people
okay here we go how are you feeling john
no i i had one flash
it made me that triplicate uh structure
made me think of beyond the black
rainbow and then i was trying to
decipher what it was in my mind
it's like beyond science beyond sanity
beyond reason or something like that
it has a cool tagline but uh you'd have
to see the trailer for full effect
do you have a hair tie or a scrunchie
hells yeah
you want a scrunchie what kind you want
you want a regular hair tie i don't know
why the other one it's hot in here
milk was a bad idea what's
the anchorman tagline do you remember
what the anchorman attack line was no
we need a moderator
we do need a third party who who is like
on hand
to like research and like be in the room
to like ping it
we need in the future we'll have
somebody running stream labs for
us or uh or it'll be easier to
there's really no way one of we can
google while we're doing this
okay so who's next on the list we got we
got our friend abigail hey happy game
miguel
uh if covent enters another year at
quarantine what do you think will happen
to the movie industry we're gonna run
out of awesome taglines
what's going to happen we'll have to
we're going to be mine
until we're running out of movies all
the taglines yeah
protect the titles okay all right you
want to go into this topic copy enters
another year according to anything will
happen to moving street i think
we're gonna see a much bigger shift of
everyone who's like nope save the movie
theater experience
um to start actually shifting a lot more
of their stuff to video on demand
i think that's what's gonna happen all
right basic summary if if that's what
happens
that's you know i mean i hope they fix
it up in the
wheat house yeah i don't know i mean
i've heard a lot of different things and
it sounds as though it's been
problematic for theaters to stay open
under the current restrictions and yeah
um
i feel like for a while we're gonna see
people i feel like a lot of dams are
gonna break
a lot of things are gonna go to
streaming that they said weren't going
to
and then i i think maybe depending on
how long this perpetuates we might see
uh perhaps an improvement on the
drive-in
circuit because i know a lot of people
have gone and that's been booming lately
but there are also a lot of complaints
the drive-ins aren't as
qualitative as they could be so i don't
know maybe that'll happen that's my wish
do they have drive-by strip clubs drive
through strip clubs you know where
it's just behind glass and you drive
through a tunnel like one of those uh
like one of those mini markets they have
in the midwest where you just literally
drive through a snack
tunnel but for strippers and then you
just pay
along the way i think that's a great
idea no one
we keep talking about the movie business
suffering and restaurants and stores
are strip club suffering yes they are
they're not a lot of we're not talking
about this this needs to be part of the
conversation they're open in florida
everything's open in florida isn't it
there's a lot of stuff open in florida
space jam
get ready to jam aj readings
good job that's a good one
cause that makes me think we're about to
rock we need a voting system here that's
get ready to jam in space it wouldn't be
strange it would have been
even better if they just went with come
on and slam because at least that'll
make you think of the song
like there are ones where you can easily
just make a shitty tag like okay
really quick before we okay what's the
what's the last super chat we have i
know we got some more that we got to
refresh this
good night mikey mcmahon good night
mikey um
oh oh anchorman they bring the news so
you don't have to get it yourself
you know what's funny about anchorman i
got a little thing i want to say about
that really fast
what is the one funny thing about
anchorman okay hold on a sec michael
swift
if you're going to give someone pain
you've got to get into it oh what is
that
if you're going to get this is a make or
break nightclub
no i thought uh oh hostile no
oh no what's uh kakihara
is that a no it's not what's the hostile
tag line i feel like
we gotta find this one i don't think
it's a real tagline
i think you're just quoting something
and michael swift you're being kind of a
trolling jerk because now you're having
this research here and wasting time on
this stream
wow i appreciate your super chat very
much so buddy
thank you if we've if we missed
something here let us know
let us know what is the fight club says
someone fight club
whoever's following this stuff fight
club tagline and there was another one i
can't remember what it is
ah let's see here greg's hair is live i
appreciate that hashtag let's get it
going
hair is life lethal weapon two the magic
is back
that's such a stupid tackle what is the
magic is
that the
[Music]
someone look up reanimator also i feel
like that's got a good tag ooh
adam teddy just said one in the chat
that's is that a real tagline
parasite for parasite
i want to write a screenplay where
everyone's dialogue is just a tackle yes
yes every once in a while not have it
make any sense
cedric pelletier the last man on earth
is not alone
that is a terrific tagline i think for
uh i am
legend that's spooky that's a spooky
chilling unsettling one see that's a
good one that makes
your shoulders yeah encapsulates the
plot encapsulates the tone
that's the key to a good tag line i have
never tried to come up with a tagline
like a good tag line oh dude you're
gonna have to now what's an upcoming
movie
i got this what's one that's been
announced okay one that's been announced
um like suicide squad the suicide squad
the the james gunn one i think it's such
an amazing tagline
don't get attached oh my god if you can
do it in two to three words
then hell yeah that's so good it's
perfect yeah again it's perfect because
it's just
it's just a vibe you know it's an
attitude all right guys i'm gonna ask
you guys for a request mischief ma'am
and soap of course thank you judith
thundersteel fight club
you're gonna ask the people you know
what you could do is
reserve when if i'm clearly
you know if you've just started a
sentence like you're two words in and i
interrupt you
i might let myself get away and be like
might do a quick apology but if i'm
sorry if i'm like
three-quarters of the way through a
sentence
and then you just that's absolutely i
had a yeah i was very impulsive in that
moment
please you have the floor good sir i
don't know i was talking about
a lot of people have commented the fight
club tagline now i am good
uh you were about to ask the people a
question
oh yeah okay if if we had to have a
tagline for the channel we should give
you know yeah if someone comes up with a
great enough tagline bradley
who created our banner i'm gonna ask
that you add
if someone comes up in this chat right
now with a great
tagline for the real rejects i'm gonna
ask bradley
who's in this live stream right now to
create
to add it the tagline onto our banner i
think that'd be a fun one right yeah
yeah that'd be fun yeah man that could
become a new thing we could update it
periodically
like equal posters i used to have it be
react review subscribe
but now i don't like that so you know
it's
i feel like now we're at a point where
it could become a little more fun
yeah like that's crisp it's not bad but
but also now
it's time to get real it's time to get
real that's if we start like a sidebar
channel where we talk about the real
issues
we should do it like the unborn where
the unborn is it wants to be born now we
should go the real rejects
we wanted to be rejected we want to be
accepted we want
to be it wants to be accepted to be
accept us accept
us three or four pandas should just be
us looking desperately for your approval
please the real rejects please clap
real rejects they got better they got
better the time to get
the time to get rejected they didn't
even make the cutting room
floor two idiots won mine
hey isn't that dumb and dumber oh
giselle that's really sweet
that's just a sentiment we should just
take giselle the real rejects are
awesome youtubers in the world they do a
great job doing reactions to family guy
in movies
that's just a good pitch that's just
a good pitch it is what it is
it is what it is i might like that
it is what it is hey this is gonna
be a great one it is what it is yeah we
have to
especially when you're kidding i'm gonna
write this down what point in the chat
in the stream is this 55 minutes it is
what it is
55 minutes i gotta write down when these
started coming in so that way
oh the reels and nipple chills
wait wait there's gotta be something to
do with nipple chills that we can put in
there
um reel it in real real we can just make
it free the nip
we can co-opt an entire movement for our
own slogan
well that keeps going which i'm loving
and i wish drunk anissa was here to
contribute because those would be
i know she'd be all over this one let's
refresh
here because i know we've gotten a
couple oh john no i'm pulling up
dropbox right now oh does anybody need
anything dropbox for them because i have
it open right now
i can help you out we can send you some
files you can generate a private link
whatever you want
uh let me see here oh okay we're all i
almost got it
you're you're so hey yo sneaks what's
going on gentlemen
jeter the realest reject nation oh john
you know what we should do
what's that what should we do okay we're
gonna go to the pin where's the chat
let's go to the pin uh let's pin one
let's say
uh okay i got don't worry guys i got
this i'm just going to keep my face
way down here yeah keep it on the down
low
what tagline would you give the real
rejects that way when people come in
they know what to start saying
welcome to the suck jar head that's a
great one oh it's right yeah well then
we could then we'll decide on
whoever has the best one we're just
gonna take that one he'll put it there
and then like every tagline we're not
going to
credit whoever it is that came up with
the awesomeness tagline forever
wondering whose fault this was they're
the reasons to see you classic i love
they're the reasons
okay so uh where are we at here
okay don't even fret bruh all things
thank you to everyone who's here
seriously i really do i really uh
we haven't streamed in a while and i
forgot how fun these are yes
i always forget how fun nice to see you
all just takes a couple of days for me
to forget something
well you know it takes 21 days to build
a habit so that makes sense uh
where are we at john do you see where
i'm at i'd see where you're at
and uh got it tina's hot dog
yeah alien covenant has run away
learning the prometheus school of
running away from things
wait so what is it what's she saying so
in germany that's the tagline
i guess tina's hot dog we need some you
don't have to
give another super chat or something you
just put it in the comments the alien
comes in
tagline was just run just tell me i
actually kind of like that though like
if if the tagline for alien covenant was
just
run and and if if if i'm reading this
correctly and the implication is that
you know being that this is the
follow-up to prometheus and prometheus
has some pretty poor examples of people
engaging in the act of running as a
means of thwarting a threat
uh you know i can guess i can see how
this would make some sense
yeah like i mean it's it's a you would
run away from an alien so sure
i'm with it well i appreciate you
informing us because that is the kind of
thing
over this germany situation that i know
john's gonna get very curious about
and then just start googling one day i
love idiomatic can we get to filming
this i'm like what are you doing like
nothing he's going to close out the
window
i'm going to see that he was trying to
find out what's up with movie tag lines
and how they're handling
germany yeah man what's the translation
how do idioms work
in all these places oh reject nations
are actually not a bad one
two real beards with long reject hair
it's for our grooming channel
uh phleb doran's asking thank you flev
can we do movie
catchphrases for next week i saw i just
saw the thought process in john's head
go off in my peripheral you guys did not
see that i just saw it great but i heard
everything
i started talking and he was reading the
chat
and then he i saw him go wait we
established that when one of us is
reading this chat
reading a super chat that we should both
be paying attention
that moment didn't saw his head go
i think in that moment time slowed down
and i could feel everything at a high
frame rate so i think our consciousness
is
uh you know collided and uh synchronized
yes
i've seen some gray ones in here in the
chat to call it real rejects
uh can we do movie catchphrases for next
week i'm all out of taglines but i
remember a lot of catchphrases
wait a minute i wish this was a town
hall
like a public town can we move on can we
i have something uh to add to the
referendums
i have a motion i'd like to pass um
yeah actually catchphrase is not a bad
one catchphrases
oh best movie best and worst movie quote
actually there's not this is a quote
it's probably not a worst one
i mean there are a couple bad ones you
know what happens to a toad when it gets
struck by lightning
the same thing that happens to
everything else hey hey
hey classic there's a lot of incorrect
things about that
not everything that gets struck by
lightning is the same thing that's fair
storm
that's the generalization because you
know lightning that's a generalization
you know that
if you hit lightning into a rock into a
rock it's not gonna be the same
thing yeah a striking a humanoid fry the
rock
the same way it's insides get real
keeping it real realizing
feel the real for real lamps
real is the real rejection we're just
going to call it you can't handle the
tooth
but thank you phleb that's a good
suggestion thank you
eric horseman back at it worst ever
from vanilla ice's movie
there was a vanilla ice movie and wasn't
made of
trailer trailers revisited let's do it
let's do it
drop that zero get with the hero
channels you visited be a trailer
reaction i've never heard it dude that
could be a meme that's that's that's
we should do that worst ever for vanilla
ice thank you
for the that never goes unnoticed eric
thank you for such a picture seriously
thank you worst ever from vanilla ice's
movie cool as ice
when a girl has a heart of stone there's
only one way to melt it
just add ice wow i can see why his
wrapped career didn't continue to
prosper seems as though you can't add
ice
to everything that's what we call a burn
here in the streets
johnny it seems vanilla
that's what happens when you burn
vanilla ice
[Music]
we are laughing and we are such
good friends two real two rejects
john and the spidey suit the raging
bulge we have the spidey suit don't make
me put it on
ice ice baby uh real two rejects
did you read that off uh what's up did
you read two real two rejections yeah i
did i did yeah
that's why when we're talking hell yeah
i love cedric's tyrone magnus's friends
i agree that might be it i think that's
the one
it should be the real reason tyra
magnus's friends and jaby coe's brother
yeah we we know tyrone magnus that is a
really funny one
yeah just one on one on one side and the
other on the other side roman
is his friends that's pretty sharp
javika his brother
um flip is saying i don't pay attention
to posters some tag lines would have a
big impact i mean i don't have much to
contribute to this conversation
it's okay you've contributed plenty flev
you've done a great job there's no need
to apologize for such
for such frivolous things buddy you
you're out here and we see you and we're
happy to have you
because hey you're at least being
exposed to many new taglines you can
comment suggestions on patreon brandon
don't worry
oh yeah oh yeah i got you oh okay oh
sophie is also tina's hot dog
the joke is from cinnamon since they
always say they they went to
okay you see that that wasn't me clear
they went to the prometheus school of
running away from things
ah yes yes which is to not
ever stop running straight courage is
immortal from thor that's a nice one
ooh okay we gotta okay we we gotta check
in
yes we on the ones where that you guys
submitted for what you should call the
real we should call the real rejects and
what the tagline should be
just load something else really quickly
load and reload
uh oh well you could pull the the chat
here so they can see what we're looking
at right
yeah all right should i do that
sure i want i want the audience no
they want all of the transparent oh
there we go all right
all of the transparency is possible
all right it's all behind the scenes
let's see here i got this i got oh wow
whoa oh that's so cool
john i love what you set up here can you
move the fan out of the way so i could
read them
tote bags a lot all right we're gonna we
asked you guys
i can't get over tyrone magnus's friends
that is a really smart
one where is it at
oh damn okay i go hold on a sec
we got this i'm gonna see what you guys
submitted
i saw somebody somebody uh shouted out
h.a
rennings uh right there they didn't even
make the cutting room
right okay sophie let's start here time
time to get real uh where is it in the
chat
john okay where are we at can you keep
attention here from the box
yes thanks that's the arrow i couldn't
see the arrow i'm sorry
all right oh
i love this one reject harder
reject reject with a vengeance
reaction rejection just got real
oh man we don't sound like a welcoming
channel
really rejected time to get the easiest
we set ourselves up to have the easiest
insults really rejected time to get
rejected real rejects they got better
they didn't even make the cutting room
floor i'm going to make
re i'm going to reel in the rejects
i'm going to reel in the region i
like that reel in the rejects although
when i'm thinking about it if the movie
was called the real rejects and then i
had a tagline for my movie called
reeling the rejects
it would be a pretty stupid tackling but
i think for a youtube tagline
reeling the reach in the right place
yeah yeah there's actually something to
be said for that one
real people real reactions that's nice
one day we'll eat before this
we love politics yes exactly
oh exactly that's what it is that would
be
so funny he's the most misleading
our tagline should just be the the type
of channels we're not yeah
cooking let's plays
fashion halls makeup tutorials
we are not
asmr the reals and the nipple chills
i'm awful ellen strikes back the rejects
got real
effort is a [ __ ] i'm gonna let this
comment be shown
uh it is what it is yes gene jeter we
should just
we we should just take the one from no
strings attached and apply it for the
real
real rejects sex friends stay best
friends
we've made it happen we've made it
happen so
absolutely yes uh welcome to the suck is
what we should say
does it suck think you reject i think
you're rejected
i love that well we love politics the
man with the hat is back in his brain
they're the reasons to see
keeping it real re uh let's see here
nice daredevil hat that's what i should
say
real rejects real nation
[Music]
heck yeah we got some more super chats
we missed that we gotta get to
apparently um it's okay it wouldn't be a
real rejection appreciate everyone who
contributes there
real dudes real reactions we should call
ourselves real rejects behind
on super chat
even when we're not live we're behind on
the super chat
yeah you heard us uh what'd eric say
first i guess you put a keyword here
that youtube's not cool with nipple
chills and hair nation
they're keeping they care about movies
and keeping their hair looking real good
yeah that's about that's about on point
it's interesting feel the real reject
the nation
yeah man red pill in y'all think for
yourselves
uh let's see here
first or sweet then they're [ __ ]
we are sour patch kids who wants to talk
about politics yes
that isn't stuff sadness has never felt
so real movies and
like that movies and stuff i still think
tyrone magnus's friend should be the
best yeah
it has to be something self-deprecating
i think because it's like it's
so it has to be self-deprecating two
guys infinite
reactions is it true that drake died
no what two real two rejects
rejected reject the cognitives oh wow
from biek in the day which was a
wednesday by the way
uh paul put on the suit uh not not
not yet poster boys maybe poster
rejecting you one reel at a time that's
that's
i like it i like it i don't i don't know
if that'll be the tagline but
i like it a lot but what we don't reject
is your subscription is your
subscriptions rejects couldn't get
realer i watch your guys
thank you andy i appreciate that good
night real movies real tvs
real discussions real okay i did see
what thank you guys keep them coming
dude how did we not get to [ __ ] just got
real who said
that i said that just now
like like in bad boys part two
i'm so happy for you john no
real people with real problems
eric horseman best tagline if you only
see
let me just make sure this is uh let me
just make sure this is really the last
one
john keep reading off the ones while i'm
loading this keep the real reason
keep the real rejects coming the real
rejects
john did well in the showdown once and
uh he did
rejecting ryan and jerry not bad uh
rejects is the way for our for the month
of december and november yes i think
that ought to be it
maybe we should change i'm so hungry
guys we might have to call we usually go
for a couple hours but i meant to call
this a little bit early because my
stomach it's kind of in pain
it's okay um and i don't want to just be
sure wait a minute jimmy jesus said
grace randolph doesn't know yes
forever tyrone magnus friends
i like it one on one side one on the
other
perfect real rejects olivia rules that
she does
oh man oh pizza all i ever want is pizza
yeah it's a problem guys two guys
talking about random [ __ ]
eric horseman thank you again buddy if
you only see me
one movie this year you need to get out
more often
from naked good that's really a smart
good one
those days the parody taglines i feel
like were pretty fun we haven't had any
good parody taglines in a while
no we got to get free bergen seltzer
back
jean jeter what's up buddy put up a
hilarious video recently
it cracked we literally clicked on it
and put up a reaction on patreon we
literally
he didn't send it to us he didn't ask us
check it out we just saw the
notification bell and we're like read
the title and thumbnail
it was like oh we got it we gotta go
check this [ __ ] out it's not so funny
this is too good to pass up may the real
be with you
i hope the watch here is a film reel
that should be us in the
in thumbnail good night chelsea good
knocked knocked
michael swift it's itchy the killer by
the way sorry if i'm sending too many
super chats
no if you're going to give someone pain
you've got to get into it
each
you can never send too many super chats
no it's impossible
to ask eric horseman and anissa oliva
they they they never do and as much as
we'd be like it's okay
real using our own tagline we'll reel it
in they keep it coming they keep casting
that hook out
hells yeah and tariq allen doesn't have
anything here
let's go check out his youtube page
what's going on
oh you look like a friendly guy tariq
you have no subscribers i love
that suit you did not give anything
to skyline you gave a super chat but you
didn't put anything there i'm gonna
subscribe
to tariq's channel and turn on the
notification bell
for the channel does not have any
content so there'll be a day
there'll be a day we are your first
subscriber
and we will get the first notification
we will get the first notification
of your first video and you bet your ass
we are going to comment on that and say
first oh hell yeah
we lost mexico
we got to read more of these real
rejects ones because they're too good to
be true
yes oh okay i see what happened there
you go yeah open up a separate window
you're a
all right and good rejects unite hey
that's not a bad one kate
rejects unite that that that has a sense
of community yeah and with the youtube
channel what you want to build
is a community that's the key to youtube
success
it's more than just keeping it personal
it's about connection
putting yourself together so rejects
unite is actually a really good one
yeah that's a really solid one
what a uh yeah what about uh when
keeping it real goes wrong
yeah you know what we should end this
stream with just a speed round
of reading it gets what you guys have
here today let's do that
yeah yeah because
i'll tell you guys i you know it's
pretty obvious why i'm tired hungry hey
there was one day where i
i only ate an apple wow that sounds like
a specific day
so there was a day oh we're gonna we're
gonna do a speed round of this but yeah
i think uh
the weeks catching up with me so there
uh i did you might have seen my youtube
story i put up
i was trying to get the clone wars
finale reaction up
and it was a four in the morning and it
just kept getting blocked i had done
like
six edits on it i was like you know what
i just need to i need to end this
i just need to go to bed i'm gonna ask
eric to come before people
and then the next day i have a very
special video
coming up that i could finally tease a
little i'm not gonna tell you
it's a pretty big announcement for
something i've been working on
and um you're in the snider if you guys
know my career pursuits
outside of youtube i think you're going
to like to what this video is all about
but i wanted to make sure i'm saying all
the right things i had to write
something that took a long time then i
had to
also uh it took like almost seven hours
to edit this video
and i had to get it out of the way to
get it so i could have the people who
i'm working with this on
approve like yeah i'm not saying
anything wrong right
and that was the day i only ate an apple
i realized it was one in the morning
and i was one or 1 30 in the morning i
think and i was like i don't eat an
apple i didn't go to bed though
i woke up early the next day by eight
now i'm gonna screw everything up
and then we fill mandaloria right away
in the morning so yeah i'm a little bit
hungry but uh yeah you guys are gonna
have something pretty
i'll probably put that up next sunday uh
not tomorrow but next sunday
um but yeah i'm i'm going to want to eat
some food
let's see what you guys have said here
who needs food sorry for it being
a kind of a shorter one today but next
one will make up for it promise
a really long hair where are we at hey
somebody comment boys here we go
all right let me make sure the arrows
all right get real
just two buddies keeping it real real
movies
real tvs real discussions real
reviews real movies real pizza
real reason but then there's times but
then there's times where i'm just not
sharp and like i feel like this whole
week yeah
it's been a like an alternate universe
week yeah my week this week i've not
been sharp
like i could they're videos that we've
put up where i'm like i'm not
proud of the way i handled discussions
and even like the most small video like
the smallest topics i'm like dude i just
have not been sharp and
uh i feel like that sharpness started
kicking in around the time of cover
mandalorian i'm like oh thank god my
sharpie's kicked in a little bit
for that one because oh yeah but i can
admit that like i have not been a big
fan of the way i don't think i've been
super sharp this week
so i want to get a good night's rest to
come back for fresh monday
so i can be sharp yeah from from this
vantage i think you've you've done a
good job throughout the week but uh but
i i i feel you on the same wavelength as
well so uh
um the sharpened rejects next week real
but i like this one that's really sweet
darth yoda two just two buddies keeping
it real
yes but what if john's not in the video
and then people are gonna be like
where's john um yeah there are a lot of
faces in the background one of them
could be your buddy for a video i'm not
in
all right let's see here a rejects is
the way
rejecting ryan jerry real friends
real reactions papa john's ooh
bradley i like this one [ __ ] just got
real
you like it do you you're a fan of that
are you
what was that about we had a whole
conversation about this like five
minutes ago
i'm
it's okay it's okay you need we we all
have a week like this
and we all need to sometimes because
it's a
good reminder of uh
that says something about my
relationship with john
it's okay it's different when you read
it
no yeah yeah and when it's introduced
just without
i probably introduced it with a lot of
uh uh clunky wordage
real rejects versus rotten tomatoes
sure i feel like we take less issue with
them over
here taking on rotten tomatoes
really long hair be real with each other
and
party on reed nation ryan gosling fan
club i actually like this one two guys
talking about random [ __ ]
with great reactions come great fans
i might just take that one eating
nuggets currently
you know what i'm even gonna pin this
one for you yeah
mirna you have replaced the pin you have
won today
you've won the day tyrone help us
i yes i think that's is so pyro
and help us oh we don't know grace that
is so funny
two men and a baby i saw that or or or
darth yoda you also come in two men in a
green baby which i also like i just love
how straightforward that is
reacting to movies tv shows don't choose
the real life the real life will choose
you
ooh that's good i like it oh that's
enough that's a good that is a good
title
real rejects ruling reactions hey hey
it's tyrone who rules yeah yeah yeah
we're we're just uh mere plebeians in
his chat oh i thought i was okay
where'd it go they didn't reject the
real the real
rejected them
what does it mean we got us we got a
screen shot stuff we
just got bradley if you're still on the
you're still on the stream i just saw
you we're
chatting right now you you gotta help
you gotta help us uh
uh like come up like include some of
these tag lines just when you thought it
was real
to go back in the regix rejects unite
actually that's not bad rejection we
talked about a whole conversation about
that didn't we just a couple minutes
yeah
we really need a tagline i like that mk
song rejects became real
he's out to oh that is the funniest
wonderful time
he's out to prove he has nothing to
prove the amazing real rejects dawn of
justice
how'd you guys not notice the really
rush riding the the recent mandalorian
episode
because we were rushing to get that
reaction out so it worked perfectly in
our times man
uh but you know i mean i i'd be
interested in hearing some more opinions
but uh yeah that was our initial
initial reaction i don't know we're
going to hell [ __ ] it
i'm with it youtube shuts us down for
terms of service violation
thank you love you too hey yo what is
that unlike other people in your life we
won't really
reject mountain i can't quit you
i want a real rejects mountain at some
point to to come into existence
all right we've reached real time stage
guys let's bring in the last ones let's
reel in the last one reject
ejections revenge of the rejects
if you get one shot make it real there's
a guy there's there's that's that's
not real oh wait we did get one more
super chat here we have to honor every
super
chat that comes in have to this is the
most real behind the scenes
oh let me just refresh this it's the
least we can do while we're eating
nuggets currently
oh my god nuggets nuggets though so guys
if you're vegetarian or vegan
um before i stopped eating meat one of
the
my favorite things i used to love to
microwave were dino nuggets right
dino nuggets and then dino nuggets
recently came out with plant-based
dino nuggets and they taste just like
the actual dino nuggets do they really
maybe because dino nuggets
are probably not real they're just like
it's already not real meat
it's just tofu that we've seasoned with
all the same chemicals
and then eric horseman thank you so much
eric reeling in the reactions means a
hell of a lot oh yes siree
oh i saw a couple good ones in the chat
yeah don't worry i'm back at it oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah
where are we at where's the one nipple
chris
wham-off there you go nipple chill
society seriously
they can cut glass
really late no no an awesome johnny depp
impersonator and the cool bantees man
gamer movie dude i like i i appreciate
that
never give up never surrender oh by grab
thar's hammer what a reaction
uh pizza sounds good it does burning
alvarado does
what if it was the real rejects
slowly hating youtube
keep loving fans or some [ __ ]
the real rejects count the votes
really
oh gosh guys you've been so nice and
this has been such a weird week for me
the extra from it's always better hell
no
i am markiplier's that was the thing i
was i was
i was actually albus twin that they
detached
your hugo in the part yeah
feel the real feel where albus john is
next we're gonna do a one year reaction
channel
guys you've been so sweet you've been so
incredibly sweet
and um your support
i have never taken for granted thank you
so much
i i mean that's not true i've taken it
for granted a couple of times
but then when i'm reminded of it i'm
like oh wow i take you for granted and
then i'm like a better person
because i've acknowledged that i've
taken your support and appreciation for
granted
and then it humbles me which makes me
proud of myself
which makes me prideful which sends me
off of the deep end
into a spiral of narcissistic behavior
you know we should do we should we
should do this more on where we have the
stream here and we can
just showcase the screen stream as well
but then there's stuff where the [ __ ]
pops up that gets hidden
and i'm like that should be hidden and
then they'll be able to see it
like what's the point of having it hit
it's problematic but
it's the thing we can build upon you
know and good night flev
reject the tube reel in the fans
bradley bradley's the one who made the
banner and he's gonna
add his own onto there see like that one
see how that one wasn't showing
we wanted to show if your nipples where
would it go where to go
your nipples are oh i got retracted what
the [ __ ] were the nipples
if your nipples aren't showing they're
not hard enough or something like that
i i will have to listen to this whole
stream and write it all down
yeah i know hi miss movies oh my god
brianna chandler
thank you kevin shepard how are you
brianne how are you
brianne it's been so long it's been my
brand and we're about to end the stream
since i've spoken to you across the
internet
all right guys well no seriously this
has been um
oh thanks it's an amazing stream and
honestly like
i i'm to put out some video really soon
and in the in the middle of making notes
for that video
i did re it really did hit me like you
know i'm i'm very appreciative for
everyone who subscribed
has been subscribed continues to watch
your videos has watched our videos
doesn't matter
and then i know we do we did find out
very recently that there's this like
page on youtube that tells you like this
is the best time to live stream based
off your audience
and i'm like we are doing the worst time
to live stream based off our audience
but but we like being here at this time
because it's usually
the end to our week so um for the few
who are here
a couple hundred to keep checking in now
appreciate everyone who's been here
since the beginning of this stream
appreciate everyone who just tuned in
if you're coming in right now so sorry
if john really wants to get one more in
there if your nipples aren't pointing
they aren't chill enough
that's what it was when your nipples
aren't showing the reaction is a real
and this tweet will be rejected
thank you guys so much i love you all
seriously oh gene
thank you for being here with us okay
look oh yours is showing up right now
let's honor really quick
i didn't know you guys reacted to what
if i just watched now you should put it
up
jean jeter we'll make it public on
patreon
go watch it yes thank you guys so much
i love you guys so much thank you thank
you for that super chat by the way i
appreciate it dude
appreciate you gene i appreciate all of
you guys
thanks for the super chat [ __ ] just this
whole last few minutes just been a bunch
of thank yous
we'll get we'll get back on our like
weekly stride soon
enough and we're all thanksgiving day
when everyone's with their families yeah
they can't be on the stream yeah you
can't be here
thanksgiving thursday thursday morning
live streams
live stream eight a.m to noon i wish i
could watch guys but
i'm eating dinner right now and will be
for the next several hours
bye guys who